Bitte schön.
Hallo schön und guten Tag.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Ciewik. Ich bin der Dienstabendarzt auf der Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, guten Tag natürlich. Wenn kein anderer Arzt da ist,
das soll man dann machen.
Okay, kurz zum Ablauf.
Ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Ich würde Sie dann direkt auch zu Ihrer Beschwerden übergehen.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder etwas nicht verstehen, geben Sie mir bitte ein Zeichen.
Dann machen wir eine kurze Pause, okay?
Das hört sich gut an, ja. Kann man gerne machen.
Okay, wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Daniel Schnorisch.
Könnten Sie mir bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname kurz bestabieren?
Ja, ganz einfach Daniel.
Ja.
Nachname ist Schnorisch.
Ich habe nicht akustisch ganz gehört.
Das hört sich gut.
R und dann wieder CH.
CH, okay, CH, Herr Schnorsch. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 27 Jahre alt.
27 Jahre alt, okay, und?
Und ich bin von 18.06.2005.
18.06.2005, okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,93 m.
3,90 m.
Und wie groß sind Sie zurzeit?
Bitte?
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Das wollte ich gerade eben sagen, 89 kg.
89 kg, okay.
Und welche Bescheide haben Sie, Herr Schnorsch?
Also, ich ruste jetzt in den letzten Tagen relativ stark.
Und es kommt relativ auch viel Schleim raus.
Viel Schleim.
Wie ist die Farbe Ihres Ausrüst, oder Schleim?
Schleim ist so richtig grün, ein bisschen gelb.
Okay, und seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerz,
durch diese Beschwerte?
Also, ich fühle mich relativ geschwächt,
dann ein bisschen müde, kaputt.
Und das geht jetzt seit einer Woche so.
Seit einer Woche.
Ja.
Und sind die Beschwerte anhaltend,
oder geht es ab und zu weg?
Also, ist es eher anhaltend,
in den letzten 2 Tagen ist es sogar ein bisschen schlimmer geworden.
Ist es weiter schlimmer?
Ja.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Fieber, oder Schüttelfrost?
Ja, auch auf jeden Fall.
Ich fühle mich sehr warm.
Also, normalerweise bekomme ich nicht so leicht Fieber.
Aber dann habe ich Fieber, das war so erst 39 Grad.
39 Grad.
Okay.
Und gibt es etwas, was dich beschwerde,
oder ihre Husten verstärken,
oder lindert zum Beispiel nach dem Essen,
oder besonders in der Nachts, oder tagsüber?
Nein, das nicht, aber das ist immer da.
Wenn ich liege zum Beispiel,
dann wird es manchmal schlimmer beim Liegen.
Beim Sitzen ist es etwas besser,
aber trotzdem habe ich da immer wieder Husten.
Aber das ist, und das Schlimme ist auch,
ich fühle mich so richtig erschöpft und kaputt, müde.
Also, richtig schwer krank fühle ich mich gerade.
Okay.
Und haben Sie geschwollene Beine, Herr Schnorsch?
Geschwollene Beine? Nein.
Nein, okay, gut.
Und, okay, grünliche geschwollene Beine.
Und haben Sie Gelenkschmerzen oder Muskelkater?
Also, keine richtigen Gelenkschmerzen, aber mir tut alles weh, das stimmt.
Also, Kopfhiederschmerzen, Muskelschmerzen,
ohne Speerzmögliche, ist es schwer auszuhalten.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland, Herr Schnorsch?
Nein.
Und bewegen Sie sich genug oder in letzter Zeit?
Normalerweise Sport, ich spiele Volleyball.
Und zweimal zwei Wochen.
Okay.
Und ich studiere, ich spiele mit dem Fahrrad,
ich bin immer in Bewegung, ja.
Okay.
Wir haben, sind bei Ihnen, gibt es welche Vorerkrankungen bekannt?
Nein, ich war jetzt vor drei Monaten, hatte ich mal eine leichte Erkältung.
Das hat eine Woche gewonnen.
Vor drei Monaten?
Monaten, genau.
Und dann habe ich so circa vier Wochen später nochmal eine Erkältung bekommen,
aber das war dann schlimmer, da habe ich ein Antibiotikum von meiner Ärztin erhalten.
Und nach einer Woche war das eigentlich weg.
Sie hatten ja auch damals Blut abgenommen, da hatte ich eine hohe Entzündungswerte.
Und aber nach dieser Woche Antibiotik war alles wieder gut,
bis jetzt vor zwei Wochen, drei Wochen ungefähr.
Da hat er sich wieder angefangen, aber jetzt ist es viel, viel schlimmer geworden.
Okay.
Und haben Sie selbst Test oder PCR-Test gemacht?
Der war negativ, also der Corona-Test habe ich schon gemacht.
Und sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich habe schon drei Impfungen, die letzte war vor zwei Monaten.
Okay, gut.
Und ansonsten haben Sie keine Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, glücklicherweise nicht, als ich bin.
Okay, das ist gut.
Und würden Sie sich schon einmal operieren?
Nein, bisher noch nicht.
Okay.
Und gibt es besondere Krankheiten in Ihrer Familie?
Meine Eltern, mein Vater hat einen Bluthochdruck, der nimmt eine Tablette,
meine Mutter hat eigentlich gar nichts, die nimmt immer aber so Vitamine,
unser Zeugs.
Ansonsten wünsche ich jetzt nichts.
Okay, nur bei Vater, der Bluthochdruck.
Genau.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Wie ich?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme, das ist wahrscheinlich alles ganz gut bisher.
Oder beim Einschlafen, Durchschlafen?
Nein, das war nichts.
Und hat sich Ihre Gewicht oder Appetit in letzter Zeit verändert?
Nein, und so mein Appetit ist noch ein bisschen ganz gut.
Mein Gewicht habe sich jetzt eigentlich auch nicht verändert.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente, regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf?
Nein, aber ich nehme ab und zu mal Ibuprofenen oder so beim Sport,
irgendwo eine Verletzung.
Und habe ich dann exkluidlicherweise.
Okay, gut.
Und rufen Sie, Herr Schnosch?
Ja, ab und zu, dann brauche ich mal letzte Karatelle.
Ab und zu, seit wann?
Wie viel eigentlich, wie viel Zigarette am Tag?
Also nicht jeden Tag, also vielleicht jeden zweiten, dritten Tag,
ein bis zwei Zigaretten mehr ist es nicht.
Okay.
Mach ich auch Sport, also von daher.
Okay, und trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Nee, Alkohol trinke ich nicht, mag ich nicht.
Und nehmen Sie die Frage nicht persönlich,
ich muss alle Patienten diese Frage stellen.
Ich habe sie irgendwann einmal mit Drogenkontakt, Herr Schnosch.
Mit Drogenkontakt, bisher noch nicht.
Okay, gut.
Und sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ich habe so eine Pollenallergie,
gegen so Frühblühe und...
Pollen und?
Gegen, also Frühblühe, das sind das heißt.
Ja, und ich bekomme dann, wenn es schwer verläuft, immer so ein Asthma,
da muss ich es nehmen, aber im Moment brauche ich das nicht.
Und ansonsten habe ich keine Allergien.
Haben Sie gesagt, eigentlich, ich habe nicht akustisch ganz gehört,
Asthma, Sie haben gesagt.
Ja, aber nur bei den Pollen, sag ich mal,
wenn die Pollenallergie sehr stark sich ausprägt,
dann bekommt man ein allergisches Asthma.
Und nehmen Sie gegen diese Reaktion oder diese Krankheiten
irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Also wenn es so schlimm wird, dann ich jetzt mir Saarbutamol ganz gut.
Und für den Notfall habe ich noch ein kortisonhaltiges Spray.
Ach so, okay.
Aber nicht regelmäßig.
Okay, gut.
Und sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein, bisher nicht.
Gut.
Okay.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall in letzter Zeit, Herr Schnosch?
Unfall? Nein, nein.
Nein, Unfall hatte ich jetzt nicht.
Alles in Ordnung.
Und hatten Sie irgendetwas aspiriert?
Was bedeutet aspirieren?
Eine Fremdkörper einatmen, zum Beispiel,
oder trinken oder eine harte Essen.
Nein, das war nicht das Fall.
Nein, das war.
Okay, gut.
Das war, hatte ich schon ein Problem nicht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Übelkeit erbrochen oder Blähungen?
Erbrochen habe ich nicht, aber ich fühle mich halt sehr schlapp.
Ich habe schon notiert.
Da habe ich manchmal das Gefühl, dass ich auch eine leichte Übelkeit
bekomme, aber so richtige Übelkeit habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Okay, okay.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Herr Schnosch, möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, vielen Dank.
Ich möchte gerne wissen, was es ist,
wenn es nur ein leichter Brunsch ist.
Ich habe hier drei Wochen eine Erkältung.
Und jetzt ist es richtig schlimm.
Ich mache mir Sorgen, ich habe jetzt ein bisschen Angst.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Zuerst würde ich sagen, es ist ein bisschen früh, um etwas zu sagen.
Das kann mehrere Ursache haben.
Wahrscheinlich könnte Brunschitis oder der andere obere Atemwege
Entzündung sein.
Aber bevor ich Ihnen etwas Falsches sage,
würde ich abwarten, bis ich die Untersuchungen durchgeführt habe.
Ja, deswegen.
Was wollen Sie denn alles machen?
Ich habe jetzt doch ein bisschen Angst bekommen.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich kann Sie total verstehen.
Jetzt werde ich Sie körperlicher untersuchen.
Und dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Und dann würde ich ein paar untersuchung,
operative Untersuchung anfordern.
Und natürlich können wir wieder darüber sprechen,
über Ihre Behandlung oder Diagnose.
Okay.
Gut, vielen Dank.
Darum Sie, dass ich Medikamente wiedernehmen muss?
Ja, wenn Sie sehr stark husten,
oder wenn Sie stark Schmerzen haben,
natürlich könnte ich eine Mittel geben.
Aber wäre es besser, wenn,
für die körperliche Untersuchung,
wäre es besser, wenn Sie diese Beschwerde aushalten würden.
Okay.
Ja, aber dann beeilen Sie sich bitte.
Ja, das könnte jetzt schon der lange Zeit reittagen.
Das wäre schön.
Ich würde mich freuen.
Danke.
Okay, gerne.
Ja, gut.
Ich bin sicher, ich habe einige Frage vergessen.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Ja, das ist schön.
Sie haben gesagt, alle Körper teilen Schmerzen.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob ich etwas Brust schmerzen habe.
Auf der Brust?
Auf der Brust, wenn ich frust, dann tut mir alles weh.
Können Sie mir die Fieber genau beschreiben?
Wie hoch das Fieber ist?
Ja.
Und Zusammenhang.
Gestern hatte ich circa 39 Grad und heute 38,7.
Und dabei ist mir gerade, ich muss auch Zittern.
Und wenn ich dann eine Parazitamol nehme, dann nach einer Stunde ist es wieder weg.
Sie haben gesagt, wenn Sie liegen und schlimmer werden.
Wenn Sie mich hinlegen, dann wird es mit dem Husten sehr schlimm.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie Herzrasen?
Ich habe es nicht bemerkt, ich habe auch nicht nachgeschaut.
Vielleicht kann die Doktor das gleich mal untersuchen.
Wie viel Treppen steigen können Sie?
Ich will nur Luftnot haben.
Alle Gemeinden fällt mir das im Moment sehr schwer, etwas zu tun, weil ich ziemlich geschwächt bin.
Das heißt auch, Treppen steigen, einen Stock wird ich noch schaffen, aber dann muss ich eine Pause machen.
Haben Sie Atmenhaut?
Ja, wenn ich mich anstreng, gemerkt, dass mich das schon belastet.
Ich finde das jetzt nicht, aber ich merke das schon.
Okay, seit wann laufen Sie?
Was denn?
Seit wann laufen Sie? Sie haben gesagt, wie viele Sekrete haben Sie gerade?
Vor zwei Jahren habe ich angefangen.
Schwitzen Sie besonders in der Nacht?
Ja, jedes Mal, wenn ich viel wohlkomme, muss ich auch schwitzen.
Aber wenn Sie viel haben?
Ja.
Vielen Dank.
Doktor, ich mache mir einen Übergabe an den Oberarzt.
Okay.
Ein Moment, bitte.
Hallo, schön. Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt. Ich habe heute einen neuen Pat...
Entschuldigung, ich habe nicht ganz gehört.
Guten Tag.
Okay, ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Wenn Sie Zeit hätten, würde ich gerne mit Ihnen besprechen.
Gerne, natürlich.
Daniel Schnosch, 27 Jahre,
stellte sich bei uns wegen, seit ungefähr,
zwei, Entschuldigung, seit ungefähr,
ich habe nicht dann dortiert, seit wann haben...
Sie haben in der Woche aufgetan.
Seit einer Woche.
Er stellte sich bei uns wegen, seit einer Woche,
bestehenden, beim Liegen, zunehmenden,
beim Sitzen und besonders letzten, zwei Tag,
Nachlassenden, anhaltenden.
Er tust es mit grünlich und gelblichen Sputten vor.
Er klagte auch über Fatig und Praxis.
Er erwähnt, zu Hause habe er 39 Grad,
fieber gemessen.
Die Frage nach Beinödem wurde verneint.
Er habe keine Unfall oder Aspiration gehabt.
Er ist vollständig geimpft und auch,
er ist gebustet.
Er war nicht im Ausland,
in letzter Zeit.
Vor Erkrankungen,
sei keiner bekannt.
Nur vor drei Monaten,
habe er wieder Erkaltung gehabt.
Oder Lungen,
Atemwegentschuldung oder Infektion gehabt.
Er wurde keine Operiert.
In der Familienanamnese fanden sich bei Fazan
nur Arterellehypertonie.
Wegeteitifanamnese war unauffällig bei Bedarf.
In Bezug auf Medikamente nehme er nur bei Bedarf.
Ibuprofen gegen Kopfschmerzen.
Er rauche manchmal
eine oder zwei Zigaretten.
Er trinkt nicht Alkohol
und die Frage nach Drogen
wurde verneint.
Er reagiert allergisch auf Polen
und Frühblühe.
Die allergische Reaktion
aussernt sich mit Asthmaanfall.
Beim Notfall
nehme er Cortison und Salbutamol.
Normalerweise treibe er Sport
oder Fahrrad.
Er studiert.
Was studiert?
Ich habe nicht gefragt,
Herr Doktor.
Dann machen Sie mal weiter.
Okay.
Ich hätte diese Frage gestellt.
Weil wegen Beruflich
oder Ursache könnte er es tun.
Er hatte in letzter Zeit
Redizierungen.
Er hatte eine Frage,
dass er eine Art und Weise
mit dem Atemweg entzündet.
Aufgrund der erwähnten Angabe
gehe ich vom Verdacht auf Kneumonie aus.
Aber differenzial diagnostisch kommen Asthma,
Bronchitis
oder so wie am fisämen
Bronchitis in Betracht.
Zur weiteren Abklärung
würde ich folgende Untersuchungen zuerst
körperliche Untersuchungen.
Einzündungsparameter ist sehr wichtig.
Wenn wir brauchen,
könnten wir Spromet
oder Lungenfunktion Test anfordern.
Nach der Entzündung oder Antibiosytherapie.
Wenn er Bakteriellenentzündung hat.
Was meinst du, was er hat?
Meine Meinung nach, hat er Pneumonie.
Keine Pneumonie.
Haben die anderen noch Fragen?
Wir geben die anderen Fragen.
Wir haben die anderen Fragen.
Wir geben Ihnen noch ein paar Ergebnisse von den Untersuchungen.
Wir hören den Patienten ab.
Sie kultieren, sie auskultieren
oder haben ein stilles Gut und hören die Lunge ab.
Sie hören im linken Unterlappeln
ein bisschen ein leichter Unterschied.
Aber ansonsten,
rechts als auf links, ist gut belüftet.
Auch die untere Seite von der Lunge
ist eigentlich gut belüftet.
Was wollen Sie noch machen?
Ich könnte Torax und Röntgen anfordern.
Röntgen.
Da hat man gemacht,
man sieht so ganz wenig im Linken
unterlappen, so kleine Weiseflecken.
Das ist mein Name.
Auf dem Röntgenbild.
Auf der Brille.
Vielleicht.
Främmt, Främmt,
Sachen oder Aspiration,
könnte es sein, oder manche?
Der Herr redet noch ganz so.
Welche Untersuchungen wollen Sie noch machen?
Welche Untersuchungen?
Ja, CT Torax, könnte man anfordern.
Wir haben jetzt Röntgen gemacht,
wir haben den abgehört, sie haben Labor abgenommen.
Und Sie machen jetzt einen CT Torax.
Genau, finde ich gut.
Wenn CT kommt raus, eine Luberpleunung,
wenn die linker unterlappen.
Wir haben den Patienten ins Krankenhaus geschickt.
Wir haben ihn untersucht,
wir haben ihn bronchioskopiert und sehr viel Schleim und Eiter
aus dem Linken unterlappen raus gezogen
oder ausgesaugt.
Wir haben eine Kultur
von der Bronchiallavage angelegt.
Aber da sind keine Keime angewachsen.
War sauber.
Er hat ein Ultraschall bekommen von Herz,
von Blumen, war alles negativ.
War auch unauffällig.
Ultraschall von Bauch war in Ordnung,
das Herz war in Ordnung.
Er hatte hohe Entzündungparameter.
Deswegen bekam er ein Antibiotikum
mit Tatsoback.
Diverse Untersuchungen
und noch gemacht, EKG und so weiter.
Dann ging es viel besser
und ist entlasten worden.
Es war eine Luberpleunung links.
Super.
Ich habe immer gewartet auf eine komplizierte...
Woran müssen Sie noch denken,
wenn junge Menschen eine Luberpleunung denken?
Woran müssen Sie denken, differenzial und diagnostisch?
Die anderen Kolleginnen können helfen.
Pericraditis?
Ja, okay.
Ich denke immer an die Lunge.
Tuberkulose?
Ja, gut. Tuberkulose, natürlich.
Aber wo sind normalerweise die Flecken
bei der Tuberkulose?
Oberen Lappen.
Aber Tuberkulose ist auch richtig.
Tuberkulose muss man denken, wo noch?
Du bist in dem Brunchen.
Vielleicht Parasit?
Aber er war nicht immer im Ausland.
Wo sind die Kolleginnen?
Wo sind die Kollegen?
Was sagen die denn dazu?
Covid-19 war negativ.
Da hat jemand den letzten Begriff geschrieben.
Das ist sehr gut.
Du musst dich kontrollieren.
Tuberkulose, Sinusitis.
Brunchenktasen?
Ja, sehr gut.
Ein Begriff fehlt mir noch.
Bei jungen Menschen.
Klar, bei jungen Menschen kann es auch sein.
Aber so etwas muss man denken.
Brunchen, auch Karzinom.
Einmaligme Geschichte.
Wer ist denn das gewesen?
Sehr gut.
Und noch ein Begriff.
Mit viel Schleim.
Ja, so eine Art Fibrose.
Sarkoidose.
Was noch?
Jetzt kommen noch mehr Begriffe.
Die ganzen Lungen.
Differenzialdiagnose, Sarkoidose, Fibrose.
Phibrosis.
Wie eine?
Phibrokistikid.
Ich weiß nicht, was das jetzt ist.
Phibrosis.
Ach, zustische.
Ja, zustische Phibrose.
Also eine Mukovistidose.
Ja, Mukovistidose, klar.
Nennst du auch Türkisch Mukovistidose?
Nein, auf Türkisch Phibrosis.
Ach so, das ist Kistik Phibrosis.
Mukovistidose.
Echt?
Ne, zustich.
Das muss sein.
Ich glaube Mukovistidose heißt...
Wie sagen auch Mukovistidose?
Ja, Mukovistidose.
Also wenn junge Menschen so viel Schleim haben,
muss man auch an sowas denken.
Es waren sehr gute Differenzialdiagnose.
Wir haben gesagt Brontcheektasen, Sarkoidose,
verschiedenste Sorten von Phibrosis, Tuberkulose,
Phibrosis, Alpha1, Antitrypsinmangel
und Mukovistidose.
Also so viele Differenzialdiagnosen.
Das war auch der Grund, warum der Lungenfacharzt,
mit dem ich telefoniert habe, der hat gesagt,
das ist ein junger Mann, der hat jetzt dreimal hintereinander
eine Brontcheektas, den muss man im Krankenhaus untersuchen
und nachschauen, eine Brontcheuskopie braucht er.
Deswegen kam mein Krankenhaus.
Ich habe vorher immer eine Brontcheetis gehabt.
Das ist nicht richtig ausgeheilt.
Und es hat sich weiter verstärkt.
Bis er dann eine Pnomenie bekommen hat.
Normalerweise sind die Dornzystische Phibrosis
zwei unterschiedliche Erkrankungen
und die höchsten Stoffwechselerkrankungen in Europa.
Also Differenzialdiagnose, immer denken.
Ja, aber wir legen normalerweise als Kind fest.
Diese, zum Beispiel, Brontcheektas, Sichtistis, Phibrosis.
Diese Diagnosen hat man eigentlich früher festgestellt.
Das ist richtig.
Und deswegen eigentlich...
Haben Sie nicht dran gedacht?
Ja, genau.
Ist das deine Prüfung, Differenzialdiagnose?
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist eine Erkrankung, die die Kinder vielleicht nicht so ausgeprägt haben.
Und vielleicht später durch eine Erkrankung haben.
Aber es ist wichtig, dass man auch so etwas mitdenkt
und vielleicht in die Richtung auch Untersuchungen macht.
Serozitis verursacht Husten oder nur Flankenschmerzen
oder Schleimige...
Serozitis, eine Entzündung der heute.
Das kann man schon Husten und Schmerzen machen, natürlich.
Sehr gut.
Lieber Herr Kollege, wann haben Sie Ihre Prüfen?
Nächste Donnerstag.
Nächste Donnerstag, wo?
In Frankfurt.
Okay, damit ich schon nachklar bin.
Und ich wünsche Ihnen Erfolg, viel Glück.
Danke sehr.
Und wenn Sie für mich Rückmeldung oder Feedback hätten,
dann wäre ich Ihnen sehr leidbar.
Ich habe für dich extra zwei Sachen aufgeschrieben.
Bei der Einleitung der Übergabe an den Oberarzt.
Sie verwenden ganz lange Sätze.
Ein 27-jähriger Patient, der im Sitzen, im Hust, im Liegen,
eine Öl hat.
Lieber kurze Sätze.
27-jähriger Patient stellt sich mit Fieber und Husten vor.
Punkt.
Und dann neuer Satz.
Der Husten ist beim Liegen verstärkt.
Punkt.
Diese komplizierten, langen, ineinander verschachtelten Sätze,
das machst du, wenn du Professor bist.
Jetzt, in der Anamnese, kurz, knapp, immer Punkt.
Ansonsten kommt es in grammatikalische Fehler,
verwechselst zu Wörter, dann kommt in Nervosität,
Unruhe und dann die Prüfung.
Kein Risiko eingehen.
Das ist eine schöne Sätze, das zeigt, dass du gut Deutsch kannst.
Aber lieber kurze Sätze, einfache Sätze.
Keine komplizierten Sachen.
Einfache Sätze.
Deswegen kurz.
27-jähriger Mann stellt sich vor.
Und dann musst du die Hauptdiagnose,
was ist das Hauptproblem, mit Fieber und Husten.
Und ein schweres Krankheitsgefühl.
Ich bin müde, kraftlos.
Also drei Punkte.
Punkt.
Dann kann man beschreiben, der schwitzt in der Nacht,
der hat Fieber.
Es kommt viel eitriger oder puröser oder purulenter Auswurf raus.
Kann man sagen, Punkt.
Und immer kurze Sätze.
Punkt.
Das ist eine.
Ein weniger grammatikalische Fehler.
Ja, natürlich.
Ja.
Ich glaube, das waren so die zwei wichtigsten Punkte.
Ansonsten war, glaube ich, alles ganz gut.
Das medizinische.
Sehr gut.
Danke sehr.